[Music]
the kangaroos is very much here
and very much queer and you're gonna
have to deal with it um so yes i saw the
video of miss alba and miss preach or
whatever the name is
you bro
did you just
oh he's showing me like everything
and with like a mirror i've never seen
the back of my head before
[Music]
falling i can't get out oh
finds it fitting to try the defendant as
an african american
ends forth you will be referred to for
the jury by the name
bondell brown
[Laughter]
yes yes
hey listen once the trial begins next
week all courtroom images of hannah will
depict her as a 300 pound muscular black
man
listen that is the most ethiopian name
i've ever heard you know what that's
five means no
hope
[Laughter]
mr hope is asking do i drive a chance
your name should have been no testified
because there's no hope for you money
i'm getting away with it
black privilege okay jibber jabber
yabba-dabba-doo
and i'll step out like that
he said
are you hoping to find a match today
yeah
oh i was not ready
it's constant chafing against the sugar
walls you know what i'm saying
after a while you start to feel diabetic
okay
[Applause]
call the police get their id say hey i
want to speak to a man i don't care what
you have to do
no
hey man need to do better uh
you two
aah
shaggy's going to go from erwazumi to
his biology
hahaha